[موسيقى] لقد
حصلنا على النقطة الثالثة إلى الأعلى، لذا ليس من
الجيد المضي قدمًا،
ولا تدرك ذلك عندما تنطلق،
ولكنه الشيء الأكثر عمقًا الذي
أعتقد أنه كان بإمكاننا القيام به على الإطلاق،
تحاول نيكي بيتيس
المشي لمسافات طويلة لا يمكن تصورها في
مسار أبالاتشي  مع أطفالها الخمسة عشر، أصغرهم
يبلغ أربعة أعوام فقط، ويبلغ طول
مسار أبالاتشي
2198.4 ميلًا ويمر عبر 14
ولاية وقد
شعرنا بكل ميل على حدة،
وهذا أمر رائع حقًا، فهو يعرض لك خريطة
للمكان الذي سنذهب إليه جميعًا
ويمتد على طول الطريق  من جورجيا إلى
ماين،
قرأت مقالًا عن
طريق أبالاتشي عندما كان عمري 12 عامًا، وقمت
بالفعل بتمزيق الصفحات وحفظها
ثم حدثت الحياة
[موسيقى]
فكرت في الوقت الذي أستطيع فيه القيام بذلك بمفردي
بمفردي، كما تعلم أنك تستطيع ذلك  "لا أسحب الأطفال إلى موقع
YouTube
قبل عامين تقريبًا، كنا نتنزه
وكان معي طفلان
وعبرنا مجموعة من المتنزهين
وكان لدى أحد الأزواج أطفال، وكنت وكأنهم
يستطيعون القيام بذلك، لذا في تلك الرحلة
بدأت بالفعل  للتفكير في ما سيكون عليه
التنزه مع الأطفال على ما
يرام
من يونيو من العام الماضي حتى
فبراير تقريبًا، بدأنا التخطيط هنا،
كيف تبدو قيمة الطعام لمدة سبعة أيام لـ 16
شخصًا وانطلقنا في
مارس،
شكرًا لك، هل
يمكنني تناول هذا بالتأكيد  يجب أن نطبخه
أولاً، كان لدينا
نظام الأصدقاء ولكن الكثير منه
كان لتعليمهم الاكتفاء الذاتي حتى
من سن مبكرة أنا
أوبري، كيف حالك، أنت من أنا
جافين ما اسمك أعني كم عمرك
كان الطفل البالغ من العمر أربع سنوات في الواقع
واحدًا من أفضل المتنزهين الذين بدأوا في
البداية، لقد قطعنا خمسة إلى ثمانية
أميال فقط في اليوم، وهذا كل ما يمكننا القيام به كل
يوم قدمًا واحدة أمام الأخرى حتى
تصل إلى هنا لمسافة 20 ميلًا في اليوم.  لقد
تطور نوعًا ما في السادسة
ويبدأ الطفل البالغ من العمر ثماني سنوات في إعداد
وجباته الخاصة التي أعدها لي، وما زلت أطبخ للطفل البالغ من العمر
أربع سنوات والبقية يقومون
بالأشياء الخاصة بهم،
هناك قول مأثور يوفره المسار وهو
حقًا حقًا،
الكثير من الناس لا يفهمون لماذا
تفعل هذا في
العام الماضي، أصبحت الحياة صعبة للغاية وبدأ
الزواج في الانهيار وكان
لدينا شركتان لم ينجوا من فيروس
كورونا ماذا تفعل بالحياة عندما
لا يبدو شيء؟  مثل ما توقعته
عندما تشاهد الأطفال وهم يبدأون في
الانهيار بدلاً من إخضاعهم
للعلاج وهو ما حاولنا أن
تأتي إلى هنا حيث تخرج هنا
على الطريق وتعيد تجميع صفوفك،
ولا تتوقع أن تكون
الحياة كما هي  - يتغير حيث أننا قطعنا
ثلاثة أرباع الطريق إلى هناك، لذلك
حصلنا على ما تبقى من 546 ميلًا، لذا
بالكاد يمكننا قطع أربعة أميال الآن نحن هنا
نقطع 24 ميلًا
[تصفيق]
إنهم واثقون جدًا في أنفسهم
ومستقلون وهو ما كان كثيرًا  هدفي
لهم جميعًا
[موسيقى]
هناك أوقات سنمضي فيها
ساعات في صمت، ثم هناك أيام
تتحدث فيها بدون توقف ويبدو الأمر
كما لو أن مدرسة ابتدائية تسير على
الطريق الصحيح وتشق طريقك إلى
القمة  وهو أمر شاق وتصعد إلى
هناك ويبدو الأمر كما لو أن كل واحد منا فعل
هذا ونحن قادرون على ذلك، وهو
شعور جيد جدًا أنه لا يوجد
شيء لا يمكننا
تحقيقه بشكل فردي أو كعائلة